[Musique]
invité de 5 à 10 ce matin claude lise le
président de l'assemblée de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
bonjour claude lise la question est sur
toutes les lèvres
claude lise resterez-vous président de
l'assemblée oui je peux répondre que oui
telles que les choses se déroulent
actuellement
on verra par la suite vous savez que
j'ai passé ma journée d'hier consulté de
nombreux élus j'ai consulté également
les membres de la direction de mon parti
et j'ai vu je crois plus de deux tiers
des élus de la majorité de l'assemblée
et je n'ai pas rencontré un élu qui
m'ait demandé de démissionner tous au
contraire me demande de rester à mon
poste en me disant même que cela
porterait un coup extrêmement graves à
l'alliance que nous formons seule
alliance majoritaire le grand semblait
et que ce serait préjudiciable également
à la situation de la marque et que ce
n'est pas le moment d'ouvrir une crise
et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs je
trouve irresponsable
ce qui a été fait et qui ouvre malgré
tout une crise tout à fait alors non
nous allons y revenir nous allons
revenir sur les causes mais avez vous
pensé à démissionner un moment oui mais
ce n'est pas la première fois vous savez
je ne partage pas la conception d'un
exercice solitaire du pouvoir auquel on
assiste
nous avions signé une accord le 27
janvier entre les adm et les différentes
formations du camp patriotique a été le
premier à cork a permis d'arriver au
deuxième tour et j'avais été sollicité
pour participer à cet accord qui a été
conclu au siège de mon parti et il était
question de mettre en place un système
démocratique on trouvait que le
précédent ne l'était pas et
malheureusement je considère prenez
devant un système de pouvoir personnel
et je les dénonce et en interne jusqu'à
mai le président de la collecte de
l'exécutif concentre tous les besoins
mais nous sommes dans un système hyper
concentration alors je dis tout de suite
que les textes qui régissent la ctn la
loi de juillet 2011 que je n'avais pas
de dénoncer que je n'ai pas voté font
que effectivement il y a la possibilité
de fonctionner comme ça mais les texte
n'oblige pas à fonctionner comme ça nous
avons un texte qui laisse des marges de
manoeuvre dont j'ai géré sa libération
des bien entendu et je suis surpris de
joie que alors que nous sommes en
principe des autonomistes et les
indépendantistes itunes pour l'essentiel
ou des régionales il en tout cas des
gens qui toussent dans cette alliance
réclame du pouvoir local que l'on puisse
s'amuser à faire une exégèse
pointilleuse et pointilliste de textes
de
de loi pour se priver de toutes
possibilités d'innovation les corses ont
mis en place une commission permanente
par exemple ils ont mis en place des
systèmes qui permettent aux deux
présidents de fonctionner au quotidien
et là nous sommes dans une situation où
après avoir voulu ce système de
gouvernance on fait comme si en fait il
n'y avait qu'une présidence d'ailleurs
vous entendez volontiers parler du
présent de la ctm ça n'existe pas il y a
deux présidents
ce n'est pas moi qui ai voulu ce système
là mais c'est le système qu'on a choisi
qui est complexe mais qui peut
fonctionner si de part et d'autre on a
une volonté de fonctionner de manière
démocratique
ce qui ne semble pas être le cas d'après
vous dire alors revenons revenons sur
les accusations vous êtes toi tour
soupçonné de complot pour faire
condamner
alfred marie-jeanne et aussi de vouloir
retourner au ppm d'où sortent ces
accusations écoutez d'abord je dirais
que ce sont des propos absolument
inqualifiables et inadmissibles indignes
de responsables politiques de du niveau
d'alpha nage et j'avoue que je ne le
reconnais pas là il est habitué à des
excès de langage tout le monde sait
comment comment de temps en temps il a
de certains nombres de de propos
excessifs je dirais bon beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs aime bien ce ce côté là mais
en fait il ya une limite
il ya une limite et marie-jeanne me
connaît depuis trop longtemps
il a souvent dit comment nous quelles
que soient les divergences que nous
avons pu havre dans le passé il y en a
eu
quelles que soient les lélés les
affrontements qui ont pu
avoir lieu il y en a eu et a toujours
souligné mon honnêteté intellectuelle ma
probité et là ils lancent des
accusations dont certaines sont
proprement diffamatoires et la question
se pose allez-vous porter plainte
d'ailleurs coûté franchement vous croyez
que je suis dans cet état d'esprit
non non mais je veux que toute la
martinique en tant qu il y a eu des
propos diffamatoires
autrement dit qui portent atteinte à mon
honneur ce vous croyez que moi je peux
mener une action avec d'autres en
l'occurrence soi-disant à 0 et nylon
pour offert mettre en prison sur fred
marie-jeanne alors qu'on m'a vu home a
vu participer
le jour de son procès participer à la
manifestation en sa faveur
et puis alors on croit dit-il c'est ce
que vous pensez que dans ma vie il y a
quelque chose qui peut laisser croire à
qui que ce soit que je puisse
fonctionner comme ça je ne fais pas
partie des gens qui fonctionnent en bas
fait c'est que c'est une pratique
politique locale le suc onu on dire ce
que j'ai à dire voyez j'étais dans un
parti
le ppm lorsque je n'ai pas été d'accord
je les dis publiquement
j'ai commencé par le dit en interne
ensuite je les dis publiquement il ya
des explications et j'ai donné toutes
les explications
alors pourquoi il dit ça pour quoi radic
at-il ces propos me réveille elle raison
est ce qu'il est manipulé
alors je vais vous dire que je subis
manifestement premièrement les effets
collatéraux d'une guerre larvée qui a
commencé depuis quelques temps non pas
simplement pour le leadership du mime
mais pour le leadership du 1 ce qu'on
appelle le camp patriotique
il ya manifestement une guerre larvée et
donc ça crée une ambiance particulière
avec de la délation et d y parle de
coups de complots
si je ne suis dans aucun complot il y a
il y à une cabale manifestement depuis
quelques temps
qui explique que certains lui bourrer le
crâne avec des éléments absolument
mensongers et puis je pense qu'il a
voulu donner un coup d'arrêt à mes
propositions en faveur d'un changement
de fonctionnement
il m'a demandé lui-même ya plus d'un
mois et demi d'animer une petite
commission vous faire des propositions
c'était déjà extraordinaire
je me suis dit tiens les choses évoluent
enfin et je pense que certains sont
allés lui dire que parmi mes
propositions il y aura des propositions
pour améliorer le fonctionnement parce
que j'ai l'habitude de dire qu' il n'y a
pas seulement des problèmes financiers
poèmes financiers sont dues à un passif
on laissait d'autres ils sont dus un
certain désengagement de l'état tout le
monde sait ça mais à enveloppe
financière égale on peut fournir un
meilleur service public de manière
qualitative en améliorant les procédures
il faut arrêter le système hyper
concentration
le système pyramidal qui fait que tout
remonte tout où on monte au sommet on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas gouverner une
collectivité qui a le nom de compétences
et de celle ci avec celle de la halle de
l'exclusion de l'ex département plus de
4200 et quelques agents un milliard cent
millions de budget ça ne peut pas ça ne
peut pas se ceux administrés de cette
manière on ne peut pas tout concentrer
au sommet wallon moi je fais ces
propositions je crois que là on a voulu
donner un coup d'arrêt et puis une
opération de diversion parce que en ce
moment manifestement alfred marie jeanne
se rend compte que il est devant des
difficultés qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
surmonter
c'est quand même extraordinaire que nous
soyons décembre et que nous n'avons même
pas encore pu voter des orientations
j'étais ce ne sera même pas le cas à la
plénière prochaine ça veut dire que il a
une difficulté aujourd'hui mais les
parquer son jeu elle veut vous ce n'est
pas de son thriller commissaires alors
je vous dis n'est pas qu'elle n'est pas
que de son fait de le sucer honnête il
ya le passif il ya tout ce que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure mais il ya aussi
son mode de fonctionnement
et effectivement c'est classique
lorsqu'on est devant une difficulté
qu'on n'arrive pas à surmonter
on cherche un bouc émissaire et on fait
une opération de diversion
donc il y à tout cela et puis j'ajoute
que c'est un homme qui est en campagne
je n'y croyais pas au début et j'ai
découvert qu'il est en campagne mais je
lui dis attention là la maison c'était m
brull et celui qui au sommet est
tranquillement en campagne en créant une
situation qui peut faire imploser la
majorité actuelle et peut entraîner un
désastre
sur le plan de la situation et comment
ils allaient pouvoir travailler
aujourd'hui avec alfred marie jeanne
je fais appel à sa raison je fais appel
à tous ce qui l'a amené je cois à
s'engager politiquement l'intérêt de la
matinée il faut qu'ils vous allez dans
tout l intérêt de la mort dit vous allez
dans un rapport de force permanent moi
je ne suis pas dans cet état d'esprit je
ne cherche pas à mettre de l'huile sur
le feu j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire je
ne pouvais pas ne pas réagir à des
propos que je répète qui sont
inqualifiables et de nature diffamatoire
et bien entendu vous avez compris que je
m'inscris en faux contre tout ce qui a
été dit mais cela étant est ce que je
dis est ce que cela meiser peut aboutir
à un vote de nous une défiance contre
alfred marie-jeanne maintenant il n'est
pas question aujourd'hui je n'ai entendu
aucune et lui parler de cela
beaucoup d'entre eux veulent en quelque
sorte une médiation
beaucoup pensent que il faut donner un
coup d'arrêt aux actions qui sont menées
auprès de du président du conseil
exécutif un peu des actions jeudi est
déstabilisante dans le cadre de la la
querelle la querelle harvey de
succession à laquelle j'ai fait allusion
et qui bien entendu touche beaucoup
vous l'avez compris le
celui qui était le dauphin à savoir jean
philippe miller d'ailleurs c'est une
position qui est toujours extrêmement
dangereuse d'être le dauphin de quelques
uns que les autres merci le temps qui
nous était réservé est terminé merci de
nous avoir écoutés
merci à vous
[Musique]